>> Greg: THE WASHINGTON POST
ISSUES A CORRECTION AFTER
ATTACKING A TEAM'S COMPLEX.
THE WASHINGTON POST WHERE
DEMOCRACY DIES IN DARKNESS BUT
[BLEEP] LIVES ON HAS BEEN FORCED
TO APOLOGIZE AFTER REPORTING A
DISASTROUSLY EXPOSE ON THE
SOCCER TEAM.
THEY TRIED TO ATTACK ARGENTINA'S
LACK OF BLACK PLAYERS AT THE
WORLD CUP BY CLAIMING THEIR
COUNTRY WAS MORE DIVERSE THAN
THE TEAM.
THEY WOULD HAVE WRITTEN ABOUT
AMERICA'S SOCCER TEAM BUT NO ONE
CARES BECAUSE IT'S FOOTBALL
SEASON SO THEY WERE FORCED TO
CALL OTHER COUNTRIES RACIST FOR
A CHANGE AND BOY DID THEY STEP
IN IT.
WAPO INITIALLY CLAIMED CENSUS
DATA SHOWED 1% OF THE
ARGENTINIAN POPULATION WAS BLACK
BUT EVEN AT ONE PERCENT THAT
WOULD ONLY BE ONE BLACK PLAYER
TO BE PROPORTIONATE OF A SOCCER
TEAM OF A HUNDRED PLAYERS AND IF
SOCCER HAD THAT MANY PLAYERS IT
WOULD STILL BE BORING.
IN TRUTH IT'S LESS THAN 150,000
PEOPLE IN A COUNTRY OF 47
MILLION, ROUGHLY 0.4% PROVING
THAT OBSESSION OVER RACE HAS
MADE THE WASHINGTON POST DUMBER
THAN AN ACTUAL POST.
AND THE ENTIRE PREMISE WAS I HAD
USED I CAN.
JUDGING COUNTRIES BY THE MAKEUP
OF THEIR SPORTS TEAMS.
HAVE YOU SEEN THE NBA?
OR THE NHL?
WHAT ABOUT FENCING?
NOT A SINGLE HEMEPHELIAC.
JUST A HACK TAKING ANY TOPIC
ASSUMING ALL YOU NEED TO DO IS
INSERT RACE TO MAKE IT
JOURNALISM I'VE BEEN PASSIONATE
ABOUT THE ILLS OF SOCCER FOR A
LONG TIME I EVEN HAVE A
DOCUMENTARY ON FOX NATION.
>> FOR THE MAN WHO BOUGHT YOU
PICKLE BALL EXPOSED AND THE DARK
SIDE OF DANA PERINO COMES SOCCER
BOOK OF SANE STAIN.
GRAPEY AWARD WINNING HOST LIFTS
THE VEIL ON THIS SINISTER GAME.
UNCOVER THE LINKS BETWEEN THE
INVENTION OF SOCCER AND THE
BIRTH OF LUCIFER.
CONSIDER FIFA HAS SIX REGIONAL
CONFEDERATIONS, THE LENGTH OF A
SOCCER FIELD 110 YARDS, SOCCER
HAS SIX LETTERS, 660 PLUS SIX
EQUALS 666.
THIS DOCUMENTARY WILL MAKE YOU
[BLEEP] YOUR PANTS WITH FEAR AND
THEN BLEEP BLEEP THEM AGAIN.
SOCCER BOOK OF SATAN, STREAMING
NOW.
>> Greg: THAT'S ON FOX NATION SO
IF YOU DON'T HAVE IT YOU SHOULD
BUY FOX NATION FOR THAT
DOCUMENTARY.
IT'S 27 PARTS, TYRUS.
MUCH LIKE MY HAIR.
SHOULD THE WNBA HIRE MORE MEN?
>> Tyrus: SURE.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
>> Tyrus: NO, YOU KNOW WHAT?
LEAVE MEN ALONE.
WNBA'S FAN BASE IS NOT OUR
FAULT.
IT'S A WOMAN'S BASKETBALL
LEAGUE.
WHERE ARE THE WOMEN?
SHOW UP.
YOU KNOW, FEMINISTS, RIGHT?
SUPPORT.
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE.
>> Tyrus: THEIR ARENA SHOULD BE
PACKED.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THIS WHOLE MISTAKE.
>> Tyrus: IT'S NOT A MISTAKE.
THE JOURNALIST NEEDS -- WELL,
THE SUGAR [BLEEP] THAT DID THIS
STORY NEEDS TO BE FIRED BECAUSE
THIS WAS AN ERRONEOUS ATTACK.
THEY DON'T RESEARCH THIS.
I GUARANTEE THEY SAW THIS ON
TWITTER.
OH, THERE'S NOT ENOUGH BROTHERS.
SHOULDN'T MATTER IT'S THE BEST
PLAYERS IT'S THE WORLD CUP.
YOU WANT TO GET MAD, GET ON
FRANCE'S LINEUP.
THEY ALL ARE 6'6" AND THEY
AREN'T FROM FRANCE.
THEY'RE FROM AFRICA OR
SOMETHING.
BUT IS WHAT THEY DO.
ARGENTINA MADE THE FINALS TODAY
IN THE WORLD CUP SO THEY HAVE TO
FIND SOMETHING WRONG WITH THEM
BECAUSE APPARENTLY NONE OF THE
PLAYERS AREING TO ANY OF THE OLD
SCHOOL STUFF ANYMORE.
NO ONE'S COKED UP, WOMEN ICING
AR RUNNING THE STREETS.
RACISM BECAUSE MOST PEOPLE DON'T
RESEARCH WHEN YOU USE THAT WORD.
>> Greg: YES.
IN JOURNALISM IF YOU WANT TO GET
PUBLISHED TAKE ANY TOPIC INJECT
RACE GENERALLY YOUR EDITOR
ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE WHITE
THEY'RE TOO SCARED TO SAY NO.
>> Andrew: DIVERSITY OVER
EVERYTHING ELSE.
THEY DON'T APPLY THIS ACROSS THE
BOARD.
NO ONE'S CRITICIZING THE
JAPANESE SOCCER TEAM FOR NOT
HAVING ENOUGH PUERTO RICANS AND
THEY COULD.
IN THIS COUNTRY 40% ARE OBESE SO
WHY AREN'T 40% OF THE SOCCER
TEAM MASSIVELY FAT?
>> Greg: BACK AT US.
>> Andrew: NO, BECAUSE
REPRESENTATION'S IMPORTANT,
RIGHT?
I MEAN THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO RUN
AROUND THE PITCH BUT AT LEAST IT
WILL SEND A POSITIVE MESSAGE.
>> Tyrus: THOSE GAMES WILL TAKE
FOREVER.
YOU KNOW HOW MUCH EXTRA TIME TO
CART THEM OFF?
AN EXTRA 20 MINUTES PER PLAYER.
>> Andrew: SO YOU GET EXTRA
VALUE OUT OF IT.
IT IS A GREAT.
IT WOULD BE FUN TO WATCH, TOO,
WOULDN'T IT?
>> Greg: I WOULD WATCH THE HELL
OUT OF THAT.
I WOULD WATCH THE HELL OUT OF
THAT.
ALTHOUGH I PLAYED SOCCER IN
LONDON AND I ALMOST DIED ON THE
PITCH.
BECAUSE I WAS SMOKING UIHOLD ON,
WHAT'S THE PITCH.
>> Greg: THE FIELD.
I HAVE TO GET KAT IN HERE.
THIS IS THE BEST ARTICLE EVER
WRITTEN ABOUT SOCCER, WOULD YOU
AGREE WITH ME ON THAT?
>> Kat: IT'S THE ONLY ONE I'VE
EVER HEARD OF SO I HAVE TO.
I LOVE THAT SHE JUST DOUBLED
DOWN.
THEY ISSUED A CORRECTION.
SHE WAS WRONG WITH SOMETHING IN
THE ARTICLE, AND THEN SHE
ACTUALLY SAID, NOTHING I STATED
WAS INCORRECT.
IT'S JUST THAT, YOU KNOW, SOME
PEOPLE ARE UNCOMFORTABLE TALKING
ABOUT RACE.
OKAY, SO THEN IF NOTHING WAS
INCORRECT, WHY THE CORRECTION?
BECAUSE THEN THAT'S ALSO NOT
CORRECT.
BECAUSE TELLING SOMEBODY YOUR
MATHIS OFF IS A LOT DIFFERENT
THAN SAYING I DON'T LIKE YOUR
ARTICLE BECAUSE YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT BLACK PEOPLE IN IT.
THAT'S A TOTALLY DIFFERENT
THING.
I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
SHE'S GOING TO BE OKAY WITH --
JUST NOT --
>> Greg: WHEN I SAW THE HEADLINE
I THOUGHT IT WAS A PARODY.
DID YOU THINK THAT
>> Kat: NO, I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
DO PARODY.
>> Greg: YOU CAN'T DO PARODY
ANYMORE.
THAT IS SO TRUE.
EXCELLENT POINT KAT.
>> Tyrus: KAT'S RIGHT BECAUSE IT
GOES BACK TO HER FEELINGS ARE
MORE IMPORTANT THAN THE FACTS,
SHE FEELS IT'S RACIST DOESN'T
MATTER HOW DUMB SHE IS WITH
MATH.
DOESN'T MATTER.
SHE FEELS IT'S RACIST.
>> Rob: I JUST FEEL LIKE FIRST
OF ALL THAT WRITER IS NOT VERY
WOKE SHE DOESN'T KNOW IF THEY
IDENTIFY AS BLACK OR NOT HAS SHE
ASKE